foreign
okay
let's do it
[Music]
what do I think about heroes well we've
all seen them haven't we swanning about
the place
with their disproportionately high
cheekbones and comically massive weapons
roughing up Bandits because they like to
rough up Bandits don't they living it up
with the common folk every single night
on a day-to-day basis I'll say the two
Heroes me someone who's breaking your
ground with fruit with veg on the
agricultural side of things
not wafting around mythical creatures
that's what they are
wafters yeah well done you see I'm not
here to slay legendary beasts I'm here
to conquer the vegetable not a euphemism
let's face it the age of Heroes is over
this is the age of innovation this if
you will is the age of death
one moment
[Music]
this is awkward
oh
[Music]
World premiere
all right
[Music]
they don't have no mercy in the land
he'll come to your house and it won't
stay long
[Music]
Never Land
shaking bones
it's been a while
so you remember that favor you owe me
I'm looking for a creature
huge sneaky
teeth like knives
thank you
no
well hey how about you guys
nobody
not helpful
[Applause]
sneaky
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
World premiere
these are dangerous times
at least that's what I hear
the Empire
[Music]
they're everywhere
but the world here
belongs to syndicates
[Music]
I want to survive
I have to play their game
looks like I'm all in
she's in here somewhere one second
thought I'm out
[Music]
Columbia
I've been held back my whole life
and now
I just need a chance to finally be free
[Music]
wherever that takes me
I'm here to offer you a way out okay
get off my ship Jalen
give me a chance
you're gonna have to trust me it'll be
dangerous risk it but if you pull this
off you'll never look over your shoulder
again
[Music]
the underworld shows no mercy
but it's a big Galaxy out there and I'm
gonna risk it off
[Music]
wow Fable south of Midnight Star Wars
Outlaws Welcome to our first ever double
feature the Xbox game showcase followed
by a deep dive into one of the most
important RPGs ever made Starfield
gaming is the most powerful of all
entertainment it transports it
challenges it connects us and it's just
incredibly and awesomely fun
that is why team Xbox is committed to
building the greatest place to play by
partnering with the most ambitious of
game creators and by unleashing the
power of the Gaming Community enabling
all of us to play the games we want with
our friends anywhere from mobile devices
to PCS to consoles
the lineup we have for you today is just
incredible
these are the works of the very greatest
creative teams from around the world
we made this show for you the largest
most engaged and globally diverse fan
base in Xbox history
you are the heart and soul of Xbox your
passion drives us and you are the
inspiration for The Visionaries whose
games we showcase today
from me and all of the team at Xbox
thank you
this next game is from Thunder Lotus the
award-winning Studio behind Spirit Fair
who've gone back to their combat roots
with an amazing Co-op raid focused
action game that is uniquely theirs
all right everybody
it's time
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
guys it's a simple job
just in and out nothing to it
[Music]
thank you
everybody hit the floor
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
World premiere
[Applause]
[Music]
I'll forever
thank you
[Music]
foreign
people don't like you very much do they
sent here to the living lands
by an emperor who couldn't bother to
come himself
thank you
[Music]
to investigate some plague
that seems to be corrupting of their
souls
you want us to trust you
but the truth is
you scare us
[Music]
the way you fight
the power you will see
you're either here to save us
or destroy us
[Music]
for now that you have all this power
what are you gonna do with it
[Music]
thank you
welcome to the scum bar the most
notorious Tavern on melee Island
wall-to-wall Rogues and scoundrels
so tell me which ship is right for you A
big ship a luxury ship a ship with just
a splash of je ne sais quoi the legend
of Monkey Island you mean Governor guy
brush but freeport's not set foot out of
that Mansion for almost a year
hey what do you think you're doing I
told you no autographs
though I see you have a meet and greet
ticket and I guess it's not every day
that you get to meet the mighty pirate
guy Rush Three Wood the legend of Monkey
Island
the Chuck has turned the memories of
this island into a prison for guybrush
well well what do we have here
don't need this
themes may be very different from the
sea of Thieves you know
[Music]
World premiere
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
hi Melina here speaking to you from our
performance capture stage at Ninja
Theory where we have just wrapped our
shoots for sanwa Saga help late too when
we first showed gameplay for hellblade 2
it was a look at some of the game's
cinematic and immersive action where
senua faced off against a gigantic troll
on the Icelandic coastline
today we're taking you deeper into
senua's story her personal Quest her
unique perspective on the world and the
intimate Journey that awaits you in
senua Saga
what you'll see today is all captured by
the team on Xbox series X
she can feel them
slipping through her soul
following the threads of her mind
she's here to find them
I want to hide
she needs her help with a promise
a question
well it's never so simple is it
wisdom has a prize
there's always a part of you that
changes
a part of you that darkens
and a part of you that dies over there
that pool
build them everywhere The Lost Ones they
are watching us
you should never have come here
what is going to happen it's time to
find out how can we make it happen it's
time to find out why are they watching
it's time to find out what are they
waiting for
what are you waiting for I'm here
[Music]
watching more than one
where are they where are you what do
they want
I'm scared
their eyes
everywhere you feel the boring into
[Music]
things what do you want me to do
well to find us
not anymore
are you ready for what you will find
here
what we will find
what if it's all for nothing
what is that
it's you
what will they do
to us
[Music]
you're my new
parts of here that are broken you can be
whole
coach
[Music]
say it you already tell them
what happened to you you
I will not let them tell she's ready
[Music]
who are these around you sir
those you have saved
or those you led to death
[Music]
oh
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
my God a stranger
[Music]
oh
surf's up dude yeah dude
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Appalachia what a sight averent
Wonderland of Promise plucked from
post-atomic flight the fruit of years of
prudent progress and determined
reclamations and 15 million dwellers
worth of keen imagination from the heart
of West Virginia to the depths of the
pits
[Music]
no matter if you roam alone or spend
your time with friends you'll find a
home in Appalachia where the good times
never end there are relics to uncover
from a time before the war along with
loads of friendly folks to meet an
enemy's Galore our world is always
changing greater puzzles are overthrown
as we embark on Expeditions into
thrilling new unknowns yes from
Appalachian settlements to Nuka World on
tour you're never short on things to do
or places to explore think you've seen
it all hey well how about this pack your
bags for an escape of Epicurean Bliss
put your rad shield on and fix your hair
up pretty because we're headed for the
boardwalk of Atlantic City so there you
have it now you know there's a million
ways to make the Wasteland your waste
home and when you hear Adventure calling
when you're looking for some kicks
answer the call of Vault answer
the call of all 76.
play it now with Xbox game pass
[Music]
World premiere
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
General Motors historic commitment to
Performance is embodied in two of its
iconic Brands Chevrolet and Cadillac
[Music]
the V series dot R elevates Cadillac's
competitive Spirit to a whole new level
with its thunderous V8 and Hybrid Power
the legendary Corvette has been a
celebrated Champion for decades
the all-new Chevrolet Corvette e-ray
continues that tradition
General Motors is proud to usher in a
new era of competition with the
innovators behind the new Forza
Motorsport
[Music]
s of Motorsport and General Motors are
pairing their strengths and Technical
excellence and sophisticated modern
design
to take bold steps into the future and
bring that experience to gamers
I'm thrilled to welcome the cadillacv
series.r and the Corvette e-ray to the
home of competition
thank you
I know you're ready you've got this
[Music]
is my timeline let's tweak the car's
performance for the next one
[Music]
foreign
endurance
and
courage
the one who knows
or perhaps the first time in my own and
[Music]
feel disconnected from Faith's flow
unseen forces move against men hungry
for forbidden knowledge of mystery long
kept hidden
that threatens to unravel reality itself
[Music]
foreign
Toronto is under attack
I know sector there's something
different about null sector this time
they've taken over most of the city and
the rounding up omnics they need our
help
people are answering Vincent's recalls
and we have so much to teach them
we can stop null sector maybe we can
save the city coming through
it's been a while as if I didn't have
enough problems already
I hate to interrupt the moment but I'm
picking up reports of more attacks in
other cities
it's a fight day one I say let's give it
to him
[Music]
Target marks
time to create things with bullets
[Music]
the world is coating on us
let's go shall we do this together fight
with me
engaging watch this
I saw that not bad
World premiere
what is this place it looks like we're
in a palace what the hell is going on
who are these people no idea but if
they're attacking us our only choice is
fighting back hey look over there
can you get us out of here so you're
telling me your thieves who steal harms
and you just happen to stumble into this
world
the rebel core will always help the
Phantoms just as the Phantom thieves
have helped the rebels
never forget that we're a United Force
who can rely on each other
[Music]
unfortunately returning will be no easy
feat
somewhere deep inside I know you realize
things can't go on like this
so will you take a stand beside us yeah
let's show them what we got
[Applause]
[Music]
Humanity has always hunted for knowledge
in the unknown
the Wonder is
not that the field of stars is so vast
that we have measured it
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
we're all here because we're committed
to the biggest question of all what's
[Applause]
[Music]
you're part of constellation now
part of our family
[Music]
we do not fully understand all that is
at work here no finer group in the stars
to be unraveling this mystery
I'll follow you from here on out to
Captain grab jump is ready I love this
part
these artifacts could be everything
we've been looking for another great
secret the universe is asking us to
unravel
human settlements throughout the Galaxy
could be at risk
we are not stopping whatever lies at the
end of this road
will change Humanity
forever
This Is Where We Belong
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
World premiere
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
World premiere
good morning
[Music]
foreign
I'm very excited to be returning his
Johnny silver hand in the upcoming
expansion for cyberpunk 2077.
Phantom Liberty
this new adventure reunites Johnny and V
on a dangerous spy mission and
introduces Idris Elba as secret agent
Solomon Reed
it's really amazing to share the screen
with you Idris it's cool to be a part of
this game with you man
um as a player
you'll get to visit Dogtown an
unexplored part of night City and rescue
the president of the new United States
of America expect a massive expansion
twists secrets and plenty of stuff to do
I know the team at CD projekt Red just
keeps raising the bar when it comes to
telling cinematic stories and video
games and I really can't wait for you to
play it on Xbox series X and S
but enough talking I'm guessing you want
to see for yourself and so it is my
honor and pleasure to give you
and introduce the official trailer for
Phantom Liberty
there's got to be a way out of this
Johnny
I'm dying
there's nothing can stop that
[Music]
V
my name is Songbird I'm an nus
intelligence analyst I know about the
bomb ticket in your head
and I can save your life
what's the catch I need you to get to
Dogtown
attention all dog Town residents
president managed to crash her space
Force One into our humble District man's
got a thousand and one reasons to want
Myers as a hostage sleeper agents time
to wake them up so nus says tossing us
back into The Fray huh station we're in
the wolf stand now
get Myers out of there time to eat back
her safety is the top priority
they catch us out here we're dead
wait hear that
God almighty
someone ratted us out
it'll be treason ain't never black and
white it's a charade V wherever she goes
people get hurt bodies dropped just one
word Songbird promised me
[Music]
situation has changed you need to know
if you're with me illusion of Freedom
draws in the desperate take your truth
be come on got iron in your head gotta
put it to someone's head pull the
trigger
do anything and do it soon I'll die
[Music]
foreign
World premiere
[Music]
I don't know
it is
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
Humanity's cities have fallen
our people's only means of survival is
to seek Sanctuary here
the belfry
you must explore this world
[Music]
find the origins of this evil
and bring hope
back to our people
[Music]
let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
together you can save Humanity
World premiere
[Music]
thank you
Adventures
[Music]
this city is a miracle of progress a
finely tuned
delicately balanced machine
what happened
but it only takes one rebellious little
gear
to ruin
everything
[Music]
if you resist my rule
if you alter our past
if you threaten what I have built
there is nowhere in space or time where
I will not destroy you
[Music]
are
oh no what did I do
any last words before my friend puts one
in your scum
now
[Music]
thank you all for joining us today is a
special day for me and the team
I'm excited to see 11 games showcased
from our first party Studios we opened
with Fable from playground games which
will bring the franchise into the modern
era while staying true to its British
style and humor
compulsion and an exile shared their
first original experiences since joining
Xbox with south of midnight and
Clockwork Revolution
and we are thrilled at how a vowed is
shaping up for release next year from
the RPG Masters at obsidian
in addition to avowed our Studios will
deliver hellblade 2 an all-new Microsoft
flight simulator towerborn and More in
2024.
later this month players can look
forward to Elder Scrolls online necron
and sea of Thieves Monkey Island
as we look to Holiday we will launch
star field and Forza Motorsport both
built for Xbox series X S and PC we are
also honored to share 14 games today
from our creative Partners like Star
Wars Outlaws from Ubisoft massive in
collaboration with lucasfilm games
33 Immortals from Thunder Lotus
kunitsugami path of the Goddess from
Capcom and more Persona games coming to
Game Pass thanks to our continued
partnership with Sega Atlas
I'd also like to congratulate the studio
zero team on metaphor refant to Zeo it's
great to be able to Premiere what is
next from the creators of persona here
in our showcase we are focused on
putting our players and game creators
first in everything we do
no matter if you choose to play on Xbox
PC or over the cloud all gamers are
welcome here at Xbox
when it comes to our consoles we have
heard your feedback on two fronts first
we have significantly increased our
supply of Xbox series X making it easier
for fans to find globally
second
we know you've wanted more storage with
Xbox series s and I'm excited to share
we have some news there as well
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you foreign
[Music]
and now for the one more thing you've
all been waiting for
prepare for the most comprehensive Deep
dive we've ever done for the biggest
game we've ever built
so sit tight and enjoy Starfield Direct
[Music]
thank you
installation stock station transmission
[Music]
hey everyone thank you so much for
joining us today and welcome to Bethesda
game studios you know we've been so
lucky over the decades to make the kind
of games that we love here and that's
thanks to all of you from the Elder
Scrolls The Fallout we love creating
these worlds and playing in them just as
much as you do and throughout all that
time we'd often talk about and dream up
the space game what if we could take
that feeling of being who you want to be
and exploring a new world but set it in
space where you weren't really Limited
in where you could go or what you could
do and that is Starfield obviously we've
come a long way since then with the
games we've built our technology and all
of us here in the studio we've done so
much together but well we've never tried
to make a game like this today you'll
get to hear from many on the team and
see so much of what we think makes our
game special so let's jump in and take a
look
[Music]
Starfield is our first new universe in
over 25 years but it's still still a
Bethesda RPG through and through where
you step into a new world and you get
that feeling of unlimited possibilities
but this time it's not just one world
it's over a thousand worlds because the
choice of where to go it's not ours it's
yours
[Music]
and it wasn't until now that we had the
technology to create it
from the rocks at your feet to the
mountains in the distance
to the people and creatures that live in
these worlds
that isn't just a backdrop that moon is
actually there orbiting the planet yes
you can visit it too
we realistically simulate the Galaxy
around you
our next Generation lighting model uses
real-time Global illumination to light
the world based on the type of star and
the makeup of the planet's atmosphere
we also have an all-new animation system
and of course you can play it in third
person
and you can play it in first person
we love exploration and rewarding it but
you do explore differently in this game
given its scale that usually involves
exploring an area you've landed in
you can collect resources
do a mission and maybe even stumble upon
something unexpected
I can't
we do love stuff and all of the items
allowing you to pick everything up and
you can view all that in your data menu
this is the hub for everything you're
doing from your skills to your ship your
missions and your inventory we love to
pack a ton of detail in every object
from all of your weapons
to spacesuits
to food we just obsess over the details
and food we obsess over food
when you're done exploring you can walk
back or fast travel to your ship we have
Companions and crew you can take with
you I left Vasco here back at my ship
welcome back Captain Howard and he can
even say your name let's head out
[Music]
our mission was to convey the Wonder and
Majesty of space exploration to evoke
the Romance of the golden age of early
space flight and we've been referring to
this approach as NASA Punk this means a
design language where the tech is
advanced yet still looks grounded and
relatable for us it's a contrast that's
where the visual interest is obviously
the NASA which is the rigid pod function
over style and then Punk which is all
about Style
you can see that visual style coming
through in your ship your ship is your
home for you and your crew and like many
of the spaces in our game it has a
slightly retro and analog touch a bit of
Lo-Fi rather than sci-fi where
everything is well used worn and lived
in alrighty what's the plan captain
[Music]
this is your star map it starts with the
planet you're currently on
you can see all of its info and
resources you can choose a landing spot
or fast travel to known locations
backing out further you can view all the
planets in the system obviously the game
is big and it's here you can see planets
that have key locations missions or life
on them versus the many planets that are
Barren but resource heavy
zoom out even further to see all the
systems in this part of the Galaxy
plot a course to ones that are light
years away this uses your ship's grav
drive to fold space and jump to these
systems and you will need to upgrade
your shipping skills if you want to jump
to the most distant ones but for now
we'll plot a course to the Alpha
Centauri system where we can find the
city of New Atlantis
foreign
course while we scan your ship's cargo
[Music]
a cleared for landing at new Atlantis
as soon as you land in a city like new
Atlantis your eyes are guided upwards to
just these boundless vast buildings it's
the biggest city we've ever made not
just in size but also in the amount of
custom art
crowds and quests
so the main focus when we're designing a
city is obviously what supports the
story we try and tell as many small
stories as possible this is a colony war
memorial it's a few moments of gameplay
that make the space feel like it's full
of real characters that are going about
their day-to-day lives it's paralyzed if
you really stop and think about it buddy
it's coffee it's also where your
adventure with constellation begins
[Music]
welcome to Constellation we have a lot
to talk about by the time you meet them
constellation is sort of seen as this
mythical group most people don't even
know they exist anymore they're the last
true explorers in the galaxy and they're
trying to find the answers to some of
Humanity's biggest questions the
artifacts are so different so alien and
I'm certain one of them reached out and
spoke to you
the artifact if you could place it on
the table here
oh my God
coming together the
shirt bill Buy in and tell
and tell side the settled systems it's
definitely an Eclectic cast of
characters you've got Sarah Morgan the
ex-s soldier in Adventurer now
constellations leader Mateo the
Theologian who believes that there's
definitely something else out there Noel
the gifted scientist and Sarah Morgan's
Protege and Walter a very successful
businessman in the settled systems and
constellations financier anything goes
as long as you have the money there's
also Vlad the ex-pirate Sam Coe the
former Space Cowboy and baron you know
what I hate about these Pirates
completely resistant to my otherwise
irresistible charm
the journey you take with constellation
is just the first that many you'll
embark on the settled systems is home to
all kinds of different stories people
and Adventures for you to uncover
[Music]
the United Colonies is where you'll find
new Atlantis the first major human
settlement in space
[Music]
live here value law discipline and the
legacy of humanity they consider
themselves the true children of Earth
you ever think of joining up with a
Vanguard help the United Colonies even
get your UC citizenship new Atlantis
isn't the only city within the United
Colonies
the city of Sedonia on Mars to this day
serves as the largest Mining facility
for the United Colonies
beyond the United Colonies reach you
might find yourself in a much more wild
and independent Coalition of star
systems
this is Freestar Collective space
but all of the freestyle Collective is
Aquila City
Stone route inn is an Aquila City
fixture
Ranger relies on judgment and intuition
to do what's best for the people
neon started out as a fishing platform
but is now known throughout the several
systems as a pleasure City where almost
anything goes if you've got morality
issues this definitely isn't the job for
you
[Music]
ryugen is hiring the best and brightest
of today for our future tomorrow
everyone has been chewed up and ground
up by Neon try not to get yourself
killed alright
outside the bounds of civilized space
there are still plenty of unclaimed
systems to explore but these areas are
also home to the most hostile factions
in the galaxy
the Great Serpent hungers all heathens
shall be made Dust In Time
a new face this is the face of a brave
Runner here to challenge the red mile
they think the Galaxy is theirs they are
wrong it belongs to the Crimson Fleet it
always has
in Starfield we're pushing our cities
and settlements further than we ever
have before it's all there waiting for
you a slice of Humanity's future
so
ready to get out there
[Music]
throughout the Galaxy there are so many
things to see and stories to experience
but the most important story is the one
that you tell
I'm the type of person who spends hours
in character creation and I think people
are going to be really excited when they
see all of the improvements we've made
one of the biggest overhauls was done
through our character generation system
we scanned a wide range of faces from
different age groups and ethnicities and
by mixing and matching out that data we
were able to create highly detailed and
diverse characters we use that exact
system to create all the characters and
NPCs you're going to see in the game so
any character you see almost always is a
character you could make yourself
hey come on come on okay take it easy
you were out cold uh no physical damage
mentally the jury's still out
you know who you are new recruit for
Argos extractors ring any bells
any of this look familiar
[Music]
you start your character creation
Journey as though you're cycling through
employee records you'll pick from a
lineup of 40 presets and that'll be your
starting point
your journey from there can be as
detailed or as quick as you want it to
be this new system has more to offer
than ever before
it's also the simplest character
Generations this we've ever had we let
the player get as close as possible to
make whatever they want with the various
facial morphs you can blend together the
thermostatic and makeup blemishes scars
piercings teeth settings it's a lot but
I think it's the most fun to use
character creation is more than just how
you look this is also where you start to
decide who you want to be that's where
backgrounds come in
backgrounds give you a bit of backstory
and starts you out with three basic
skills from Chef to Dusty you know the
crew still has a betting pool about
which restaurant critic you must have
crossed to wind up here what's great
about backgrounds is you never know when
yours is going to come in handy you
could be in the middle of a fancy
restaurant talking to some guy and
suddenly you learn he needs a beast
hunter to help track down a monster fine
I probably should stick to professionals
anyway given what happened the last time
we're also giving you the option to
customize your build even further by
letting you pick up the three traits
traits are completely optional and they
come with their own advantages and
disadvantages you could choose to meet
your biggest fan
is it really really you
he'll join your crew and it'll give you
gifts if you're willing to put up with
this constant commentary I can't believe
I get to stand near you breathing the
same air I've got to have every molecule
my favorite trait is kid stuff you have
to pay some credits to support your
parents but they're very sweet and it's
really fun to go visit them honey we got
ourselves a visitor oh my God I came
across some hostile zealots in space but
because I had chosen a trait that made
me the same religion as them I was able
to get by without any issues
there's another great one that gives you
a damage Buff when your health is low
but mercenaries will randomly show up
and try to kill you
no matter what you choose there will be
plenty of ways for you to tell your
story and if you want to remove a trait
there are ways to do that too what a
view It's A Feast for the eyes off we go
to another adventure
we'll let you discover that on your own
[Music]
once you've built the perfect character
that's when your journey can really
begin
we took what we loved about skills and
perks from our previous games and put
them together to create an all-new skill
system
each time you level up you get a skill
point which can be used to unlock or
rank up skills
thank you
ranks are unlocked by completing
challenges associated with that skill
become increasingly difficult as you
work your way to higher ranks
with our five different skill trees and
four ranks per skill there's a lot to
choose from
[Music]
LG skill because it lets you mind
control aliens
[Music]
boost pack out of the gate I'm boost
packing everywhere
fixing out my physical tree so I can get
neuro strikes and just punch my way
through combat
that one's a lot of fun
invest in the skills that suit your play
style
I'm very much a stealth player so I'm
out there pickpocketing everyone
my favorite part about being stealthy
slowly creeping through vents like
you're in a movie
and then jumping out and springing on
people
whenever possible I like to talk my way
through situations is there is off
limits
[Music]
fine I'll issue you an access card I'm
more of a run and Gun player
I like doing the death from above thing
where I boost pack over guys and I throw
landmines at them
mama
to pay for that
I like blowing stuff up
[Music]
exploration is a key aspect of all our
games
in Starfield there are full star systems
with new life resources and Adventures
[Music]
our team worked hard to strike a balance
between fun and realism we study data
from NASA and a multitude of other
sources to help us make the world feel
believable
from the way we approached planetary
atmospheres to the way we place biomes
based on the planet's distance from the
Sun
once we had created a grounded world we
could start looking at all the things
that make that world fun
when you leave a planet and head into
space
you'll be navigating asteroid Fields
having chance meetings with interesting
strangers dog fighting in space and
exploring derelict ships
[Music]
it's all out there
ultimately it's about rewarding your
curiosity because whether it's on the
surface of a planet the alleys of a city
or the vastness of space
you never know what you'll find
[Music]
space exploration is possible thanks to
your ship your ship is almost like
having another character or home you can
make all your own I think you'll be
blown away by the amount of stuff you
can do
and buy a ship I'm sure you can find
something you like customize and upgrade
that ship
and hire a crew to keep it up and
running
and it all starts in spaceports
[Music]
every Spaceport has a ship technician
where you can purchase sell and modify
ships anything I can help you with
maybe you start off with a speedy
fighter that's perfect for bounty
hunting
then you might round out your ship
roster with a hulking space braider to
run cargo missions or even do a little
smuggling
for now though we're going to take our
starting ship the frontier
and make some changes
you can customize and upgrade everything
you see here
and you have two ways to do that
you can quickly upgrade individual
systems like your weapons or Shields
or you can deep dive and enter the
shipbuilder mode here you can change
anything from the systems to the look
and layout
adding a new habitat module can give you
more room for crew
calling can change your ship's overall
silhouette
improved grab Drive allows for longer
distance space jobs
you can even fully customize your paint
job to get the exact look you want
the parts you choose to build with don't
just affect your ship's stats
they'll also affect what you can do
inside your ship
you can have modules for crafting
or for storing and displaying your
weapons
starfield's in-game ship manufacturers
bring their own look and feel to every
piece of your ship
from living quarters to cargo holds mess
halls and control rooms
[Music]
our modified Frontier is a practical
ship but with a little creativity your
ship can look like almost anything you
want
but one of my favorite ways of
customizing ships is a
[Music]
platypus as I called it
where I had like a giant tail to it
and we've done spiders we've done mix
so it's really whatever your imagination
is
and while you can build your home Among
the Stars the way you want to you're
probably not the only person who will
call your ship home
[Music]
ready to lift off when you are captain
Jin's ready
Frontier is fueled and ready captain
some of the members of constellation can
join you on your journey these
companions can serve on your crew and
they'll always be there when you travel
we'll be traveling together until we
either find an artifact or this lead
Runs Dry
[Music]
each companion comes with their own
valuable skills for your ships and
outposts as well as unique quest lines
eventually some friendships might
blossom into romance I don't know that
I've ever really loved anyone
except you and if you're looking for a
little extra help on your ship you can
always hire additional crew at
spaceports got any room on your ship for
someone like me
[Music]
you'll also meet potential crew members
out in the world still think there might
be a spot for me on your ship I gotta
get off this rock
assigned crew to your ship or outposts
and their unique skills will affect how
they run
and just like companions most crew
members can lend a hand in the field
take Bosco for instance he's designed
around the core basics of the NASA
machine please avoid getting shot you
might die I still want to give it almost
a humanoid personality so I elongated
the limbs this tends to make him feel
more human-like and give him a little
personality it is a shame exploration
requires so much Bloodshed
using the ship building tools and crew
selection features in Starfield you'll
be able to build and Captain the ship of
your dreams
[Music]
let's take to the sky
we're putting you in the cockpit of your
very own spaceship and telling you that
you can do pretty much anything and that
is really cool for us as Developers
space flight should be exciting and
dangerous and you should feel like
you're in complete control every step of
the way
did that sense of control to ship combat
it's not about just hitting your
triggers to fire your weapons
complex dance between your piloting
skills and our power allocation system
boosting power to your engines will make
your ship faster
the crowd dries will shorten the amount
of time it takes before you can make a
jump
foreign
to your weapons and shields means you're
ready for a fight
you should always be on your toes
because you're not alone out there
[Music]
unlocking the Target and control system
skill will allow you to zero in on
specific subsystems of the ship you
target
foreign
after destroying an enemy ship you can
loot The Remains from your cockpit
you can always turn any ship that
engages you into scrap
but you can also take a more personal
approach by docking with the Enemy
vessel and boarding their ship
once you've taken control of an enemy
ship it's yours
added to your Fleet and retrieve it at
any Spaceport
[Music]
but space is way more than fighting for
your life
just like when you're PlanetSide there
are plenty of sights to see and stops to
make on the way to your next adventure
like these massive star yards
up the Halls talk to the crew maybe get
talked into buying a whole new ship a
civilian in my style yard let's see
about getting you a proper ship one
worthy of you maybe you'll dock with a
gigantic Battleship like the UC
vigilance
[Music]
foreign
or rub elbows with the Galaxy's wealthy
Elite on a cruise ship fit for the Stars
there are plenty of personal encounters
to be had as well you can hail any ship
you come across to trade swap info or
maybe even commit an act of piracy let's
do this when I'm playing I generally go
crazy I definitely go like the more
piracy routes I want to take over ships
I'm going to board ships I'm like this
is now mine I steal all these sandwiches
and put them you know in my cargo hold
that I have specifically for sandwiches
I don't want to play the hero but I want
to go out and just start taking things
from people as quickly as possible
strangers might be looking for a little
human Connection in the darkness of
space
hello stranger I just finished cooking
up some food
but come on over just pop on by some of
the best moments are the ones you
discover on your own
the thing I love most about Starfield is
that it is a Bethesda game through and
through it's really about going to
strange new places meeting interesting
people and getting sidetracked on zany
Adventures then realizing two hours
later that you're involved in a
completely new story you'll
we thought we were the only ones to
leave Earth that DNA is so present here
it's in our Random Encounters it's in
our handcrafted quests
and it feels so cool to play it and just
make your own path in this universe
there are over a thousand planets out
there just waiting for you to visit
[Music]
planets exploring every inch of a mostly
untouched Galaxy
[Music]
fear
we're giving you a massive playground
and a ton of toys and just setting you
free
[Music]
all right
everybody we've shown you so much stuff
but we thought we'd just take a little
break and show you something a little
bit different you know we put so much
detail into our game worlds and we love
the opportunity to bring that into the
real world with our Collector's Editions
and for this game uh we've done a watch
it is the constellation Explorer's watch
this is the watch that you actually get
in the game that acts as part of your
HUD where it's the compass and then
environmental information it connects to
your phone to give you notifications and
other information and we've also
designed this really cool case that it
comes with esfund
yeah we really took as much care and
designed as cases we did to watch our
attention to detail in the game totally
translates to this inspired by the cases
that the astronauts used during the
Apollo era to bring back samples from
the moon it's got to intricate locking
mechanism authentic heavy comes with a
constellation patch native strap and the
overall functionality and believability
of this as something that would exist in
the world in the Starfield Universe oh
and hey take this you'll find it very
useful out there and it even tells the
time
we actually have something else now that
we're part of Xbox we get to work with
the amazing people on the Xbox Hardware
team and together we have created this
custom limited edition Starfield
controller it's awesome it is now you
know our favorite controller we love
this because it's inspired by the actual
controls of your spaceship
and not only that
we've created the first ever custom
headset with Xbox and this is a perfect
pairing with that controller
run
people ready to start
ready
for departure
[Music]
in every one of our games we always put
so much care into all those little
details that breathe life into our
worlds
but Starfield isn't just a Bethesda game
studios world it's a Bethesda game
studios Galaxy
so why go this big with Starfield
because we want to give you freedom on a
galactic level
freedom to experience both the exciting
planets and The Quiet Ones
[Music]
scanning a planet before you land is a
great way to get a sneak peek at the
available resources you can use for
crafting building and customizing I
think what's cool about this whole
system that we we generate the planet
itself as a procedural content but the
handcrafted content itself comes as the
player explore
our system builds a planet as the player
approaches it and we stitch together the
luck of terrain after that we have the
system that adds interested in locations
for the player to explore creatures to
encounter
or and plans to pick up
it allows us to add that touch of
environmental storytelling that Bethesda
is known for
teachers have been disrupting our
experiments their habitat isn't far from
here if you could take care of them for
us we would be in your debt so even if
your friends were to visit the same
planet that you had you would have a
different story to tell
[Music]
thank you
it's completely up to you how you want
to interact with each planet whether you
want to explore and see what you can
find
Harvest resources and be on your way
simply taking the views
with the help of your scanner you'll
chart the Uncharted and discover exotic
wildlife
have the skills you can even figure out
that certain creatures and plants you
can build an outpost and produce
resources from those plants and animals
you can get experience and rewards for
fully surveying planets and fully
surveying a whole system
we're concepting these creatures we
really wanted to think of them as
natural to the environment we didn't
want alien monsters we wanted native
wildlife
something you've never seen before
when it comes to our exteriors when the
sun moves all that light is calculated
in real time through the atmosphere
our biggest goal for lighting with
Starfield was to make the game feel more
filmic to use lighting and color to
really make it feel more cinematic
[Music]
thank you
after some exploring you can find a spot
to set up a base camp
[Music]
outposts can be built almost anywhere on
any planet and the habitat modules come
in all shapes and sizes filling all
different purposes you can even live in
them assign crew and companions to work
at your outposts for added bonuses and
set up extractors to harvest resources
while you're away
something cool we have this time is we
have a new flycam where you can toggle
between on foot building or you can now
use a top-down isometric camera which
helps plan out larger parts of the
Outpost and placing those larger halves
so that way you can really plan your
structures and what the overall feel of
your Outpost is and then when you're on
your feet you can really decorate and
fine-tune things much easier
foreign
[Music]
and research stations in your Outpost to
utilize any resources you find or
already have
[Music]
mod your weapons to adapt them to your
playstyle different weapon sights and
Scopes larger magazines a selection of
grips and barrels different ammunition
like Explosive Rounds
all you stealth players out there will
surely need a suppressor
to go Hands-On with melee weapons
I think it's always a delicate balance
between like what's realistic what's Sim
and what's Hollywood and I think we sort
of err on the side of like what's fun
for the player
with Starfield we've completely
overhauled our combat
it's more Dynamic the animations are
more fluid
it just feels great
[Music]
we probably have more mods and more
weapons in this game than I want to say
any other game we've done before
there's a lot of variety
upgraded gear is just one of the many
factors to pay attention to when
engaging in combat you may need to
switch things up based on your
environment
gravity is different for each planet and
boost packs are excellent for getting
around
and for giving you an edge in combat
[Music]
sometimes you'll even feel like you're
flying
[Music]
zero gravity environments pose a
different challenge firing a ballistic
weapon in zero g will actually push you
backwards
energy weapons on the other hand offer a
more stable shooting experience
[Music]
we also have mag weapons
these are high-powered electromagnetic
induction ballistic arrays each Barrel
has its own targeting laser and can dish
out some serious damage
foreign
whether you want to get up close and
personal with your own two fists or you
like more compact weapons like pistols
and submachine guns
or maybe you prefer something bigger
starfield's got you covered
[Music]
[Applause]
um
foreign
[Music]
thanks again for being with us today we
are just so grateful that you've taken
the time and spent it here I know there
was probably a lot to take in there's a
lot to the game even more than we could
show here you know as we play it we're
always sharing these unique and special
moments that only a game like this can
bring when I think about what makes it
special it really is the people here
this game is a reflection of the
incredible and passionate team that made
it all of them putting something special
of themselves into it so let's hear some
of their favorite moments
I love the way that our final
combination of all the new tech has come
together to create some of the most
beautiful sunsets and sunrises we've
ever had in any of our games I love the
creatures the exploration every biome is
different the word that comes to mind is
vast
I like to use our photo mode to take
Rockstar photos
just love that constant feel of
Discovery and wow I can't believe that
there's more here I'm most excited about
our Outpost Building Systems
my favorite part is every time you step
out on a planet it's a unique experience
spent all this time building your ship
and you see it on the landing pad these
things are gigantic it's the kind of
thing that you just can't get anywhere
else there's something about seeing a
tower over in the distance and going I
know the gravity is low here I think I
can make that jump my favorite part is
biomes spaceships audio design planets
the day night cycle those details matter
to me diplomacy exploration Freedom the
ending basket obviously I love the robot
so much the incredible amount of Worlds
we created sniper rifles come on lever
action rocket launcher brain sprout
[Music]
I love but some people might find creepy
oh that's right band
the thing that I enjoy most about the
game is the freedom to be who you want
to be do what you want to do
it's what you've come to expect from a
Bethesda title but on a much bigger
scale
[Music]
on behalf of all of us we can't wait for
you to play Starfield and make your own
special moments
[Music]
um